en el vídeo anterior hablamos sobre la
fórmula de hoy leer y también cómo
extraer el seno y el coseno de la
fórmula de hoy leer aquí tenemos un
conjunto poderoso de expresiones
relacionando exponenciales con senoidal
es
ahora quisiera darles un vistazo previo
a lo que veremos con nuestro análisis de
circuitos de corriente alterna cómo
vamos a utilizar estas expresiones y
estas fórmulas este coseno es una señal
de la vida real supongamos que
construimos algo cuya señal es un coseno
podría ser algo como un micrófono que
escucha sonidos que son senoidal es y
modelamos estas ondas como cosenos y se
encuentran en un sistema electrónico
vamos a hacer un dibujo de la
aproximación que vamos a usar lo que voy
a hacer es dibujar un circuito que yo me
estoy imaginando que voy a construir hay
resistencias y capacitores hay
inductores elementos lineales y podemos
incluir fuentes y cosas por el estilo
así que tenemos algo aquí algo que va a
entrar aquí y algo que va a salir de
aquí voltajes y corrientes que salen
voltajes y corrientes que entran voy a
alimentar mi circuito con un tipo de ese
no ideal
estás en hoy dal tiene cierta amplitud y
va a ser coseno de omega t omega es la
frecuencia t es el tiempo es la amplitud
de la señal que va a entrar aquí esta
señal va a entrar a este circuito algo
va a suceder aquí y va a salir un
voltaje tendremos un voltaje de salida
por acá que va a tener cierta amplitud
que llamamos ve y va a ser un tipo de
onda coseno de omega t más un desfase o
algún ángulo nuestro trabajo va a ser
encontrar esto el análisis de circuitos
de corriente alterna ponemos una señal
de corriente alterna como entrada vamos
a obtener otra señal de corriente
alterna este va a ser el resultado
que va a lucir como la entrada va a
tener la misma frecuencia pero va a
tener un ángulo de desfase y para hacer
esto hay una cantidad bastante grande de
trigonometría dura con la que vamos a
tener que trabajar para hacer esto hay
muchos senos y cosenos y ángulos aquí
adentro por lo que es un análisis algo
complicado y lo que hacemos con la
fórmula de hoy leer es que las
transformamos en exponenciales ya
sabemos cómo resolver exponenciales así
que tomamos el mismo circuito y tiene
exactamente las mismas cosas adentro
resistencias y capacitores es
exactamente el mismo circuito y tiene el
mismo puerto de salida y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es básicamente tomar este
cosena y vamos a transformarlo en
exponenciales
lo que hacemos es usar la fórmula de oil
air y básicamente vamos a crear dos
fuentes dos fuentes separadas que son
fuentes exponenciales esto será entre 2
por el ala j omega t que es esta fuente
de acá y la fuente de aquí abajo es
entre dos por el ala menos j omega t
recuerden que la fórmula de hoy les dice
que el coche no es igual a esto de aquí
por lo que el voltaje aquí va a ser el
mismo y lo que hicimos fue describir
exactamente esta onda coseno con estos
dos exponenciales imaginarios ahora yo
no puedo construir estas fuentes en mi
taller esto es algo que no existe no
existe en la vida real pero sí puede
existir matemáticamente existen en mi
mente y yo sé que si sumo estos dos
voltajes juntos voy a obtener un coseno
así que en nuestra mente y en el papel
podemos alimentar circuitos con esto no
podemos construirlos físicamente pero sí
podemos construirlos en papel y ahora
que tengo dos fuentes puedo usar el
principio de superposición este es otro
uso de la poderosa idea de superposición
así
usando esta idea voy a aplicar cada una
de estas entradas una a la vez y después
voy a sumar los resultados así que aquí
voy a tener dos salidas aquí voy a tener
mi voltaje de salida 1 que le voy a
poner más que es lo que ocurre cuando yo
uso esta fuente positiva y apago esta de
aquí abajo voy a tener una salida
positiva y cómo resolvemos una ecuación
diferencial cuando tenemos como entrada
una exponencial pues nosotros sabemos
que vamos a tener un resultado
exponencial vamos a tener una constante
que multiplica
a la jota omega t más cierto ángulo y a
esto le voy a sumar el voltaje de salida
negativo que voy a tener al quitar esta
entrada y dejar solamente esta de abajo
usando superposición y el voltaje de
salida para esta fuente de acá
va a ser igual a otra cam a ésta vamos a
llamarla acá positiva ya está acá
negativa que multiplica a ala - j omega
t más
más
así que tengo como entrada dos
exponenciales y sé que voy a tener como
salida otras dos exponenciales y ahora
usamos la fórmula de oyler para combinar
estas dos exponenciales podemos usar
estas dos exponenciales para obtener
nuestro coseno que será nuestra señal de
salida real y esto tendrá una magnitud
de no conocemos cuáles serán las
magnitudes aún pero conocemos cuál será
la forma de esta onda si se fijan esto
es lo mismo que esto de aquí y lo
hicimos descomponiendo nuestro coseno de
entrada en exponenciales hacemos pasar
cada exponencial a través del circuito y
lo re combinamos para obtener nuestro
coseno y hacemos todo esto porque es
mucho más sencillo resolver ecuaciones
diferenciales usando exponenciales en
lugar de senoidal es así que aquí no van
a tener el doble de trabajo resulta que
esta solución que tenemos al usar el
exponencial negativo el resultado va a
ser exactamente igual que el del
exponencial positivo etc
por este conjugado complejo de aquí así
que para señales reales que entran estas
salidas siempre van a ser exponenciales
conjugados complejos
siempre y cuando tengamos como entrada
una entrada real este fue un repaso de
la ecuación de oyler y un vistazo de
cómo haremos el análisis de circuitos de
corriente alterna usando esta poderosa
herramienta